hi i'm lazar
and i'll talk about dynamic matchings
under vertex updates
this is a joint work with hung shy and
origin
this work concerns graph matching
which is a fundamental problem and has
been extensively studied
matching is simply a set of destroying
edges
throughout this torque i'll use n to
denote the number of vertices in the
graph and km to denote the matching
we will be interested in maximum
cardinality matching or mcm which is a
matching of maximum possible size
the main focus of this talk is maximal
matching or mm which is a metric to
which we cannot add any edge
it is well known that maximal matching
is a two approximation to mcm
and besides mm which is the main focus
of this talk we'll also be interested in
better than two approximates mcm
we study matching algorithms in dynamic
setting
in the standard dynamic setting
with edge updates there are many results
this is to be contrasted with the
setting with vertex updates
where the literature is very sparse in
addition the algorithms work either
either in the incremental setting
where we have vertex insertions or the
decremental setting where the vertices
leave the graph
there are only a few results in the
context of vertex updates and one of
them is for fully dynamic graphs where
we have both insertions and deletions
intertwined
this work initiates the study of fully
dynamic matching algorithms under vertex
updates
let's see an example of a fully dynamic
algorithm for maintaining a maximal
matching
in the standard setting with edge
updates
we have a sequence of updates and the
current state of the graph is denoted by
gi here ti denotes the update time which
is the time it takes for the algorithm
to update the matching
there are two notions of update time
the first one is worst case update time
which is maximum of ti
and the second one is amortized update
time which is average
di there are several results for dynamic
maximal matching
there is a deterministic algorithm which
spends linear time following every
update
and the state of the art is square root
of m by name and insole
in the context of randomized algorithms
psg shows how to maintain a maximal
matching in of log and time
which was subsequently improved by
solomon to a constant update time
there are also results for bounded or
vericity graphs
arboricity of given graph g is the
minimum number of forests required to
decompose g
and this is a parameter that ranges from
one to square root of m
note that the state-of-the-art
deterministic algorithm for general
graphs has polynomial update time
another problem of interest is better
than 2
mcm
we have several deterministic algorithms
with different tradeoffs
there are randomized algorithms for
general graphs
and also for bipartite graphs under
adaptive adversaries
for the restricted graph families we
have several results for bounded and
vericity graphs
there is also trade-off for a boundary
degree graphs
and our recent result gives a one plus
epsilon approximation for the graphs of
bonded neighborhood independence
this parameter is equal to the size of
largest independent set
in the neighborhood of any vertex
there are also one plus epsilon
approximate algorithms for incremental
and decremental setting
as it is the case for mm
the state of the art for deterministic
better than to approximate mcm is
polynomial update time
we now switch our focus to dynamic
matchings and the vertex updates
here we see an example of algorithm
which maintains a maximum matching and
again we use gi to denote the state of
the graph following
each update and ti to denote the i
update time
here the notion of worst case update
time remains as before
but the definition of amortized update
time is different
it is now the total run time divided by
the overall number of edges inserted to
or deleted from the graph
one notion that we'll be interested in
is the recourse bound
this is the number of changes to the
matching per update step
and similarly to the update time
the bond on the recourse can be either
worst case or amortized
we'll be particularly interested in the
worst case bounds
there is a recent theorem which says
that for any gamma t and epsilon
any gamma approximate mcm algorithm with
update time t
can be transformed as a black box to
another algorithm
which has a slightly worse approximation
guarantee and update time
but has a worst case bound on the
recourse of one over epsilon
this theorem applies to both settings
edge and vertex updates
we now present the previous results on
matching under vertex updates
all the results concerned bipartite
graphs where one site is fixed and the
other side dynamically changes
in the incremental model the vertices or
clients appear dynamically together with
their neighboring edges
the other version is decremental
there we have clients leaving the graph
following each update
as i mentioned before the previous
results either applied to incremental or
the decremented setting
in particular boise
give an algorithm which runs in of m
square root of n time
has an amortized recourse of over square
root of n and it applies to either
incremental or the decremental setting
there is also one plus epsilon
approximates mcm with an amortized
recourse of 1 over epsilon also for
either incremental or decremental
setting
and finally there is a exact mcm
algorithm with an amortized recourse of
log squared of n
and it applies to incremental setting
note that all these results uh
for for all of these results we can get
a worst case recourse bound of one over
epsilon by applying the theorem of ss21
for the first and the third result the
matching is no longer exact but for the
second result we get the same
approximation with the same runtime
this work
draws connections between dynamic graph
algorithms and the online algorithms to
understand the connections let's first
see the main goals of each of the areas
for dynamic graph algorithms we usually
consider edge updates whereas in the
online algorithms we usually consider
vertex updates and the graphs are
increment
the main optimization criterion in the
dynamic algorithms is update update time
whereas in the online algorithms the
main criterion is the competitive ratio
finally we can revoke the decisions in
dynamic algorithms whereas the decisions
in the online algorithms are usually
irrevocable
previous results on dynamic matchings
and the vertex updates were inspired by
online algorithms and as i mentioned
before
they are either incremental or
decremental this paper initiates the
study of fully dynamic matchings under
vertex updates
i'll now summarize our main results
the first observation concerns what we
call the basic dynamic setting where we
have a bipartite graph with one side
fixed
the vertices on the other side undergo
both insertions and deletions
here we observe that there is a simple
maximal matching
algorithm with a constant advertised
update time
in addition this algorithm never removes
an edge from the matching and we call
such an algorithm irrevocable
we note that
irrevocable algorithm for maximal
matching implies that the worst case
bound on the recourse is constant
we also give a lower bound for what we
call the medium dynamic setting in this
setting we have a bipartite graphs with
both sides dynamically changing
our lower bound says that an irrevocable
algorithm with a runtime of
n to the one minus zeta for any fixed
data would refute the one v conjecture
and also the update time of m to data
for some fixed data would refute the
triangle detection projection
next we consider the setting which we
denotes by medium decremental
in this setting we have a bipartite
graph where the vertices on both sides
can leave the graph
with a couple of more technical insights
we can show that the same bound
applies to medium decremental setting
which is more just restricted
so what we get here is in fact
a stronger lower bound
in order for it to hold into the
decremental setting we have to assume
either that the initial matching is
fixed or that the sequence of deletions
is preceded by a batch of insertions
it would be interesting to see if
the same lower bound applies without
making these assumptions
we contrast this polynomial lower bound
on the update time for irrevocable
algorithms with a constant upper bound
for one revocable algorithms
in fact our
upper bound applies to a more general
setting which we call general dynamic
where we have general graphs and the
vertices can both be inserted to or
deleted
and deleted from from the
graph we present a maximal matching
algorithm for this setting which has a
constant amortized update time
in addition this algorithm is one
revocable which means that it can remove
at most one edge from the maintaining
matching
here we distinguish between removals
caused by the algorithm and what we call
deletions of a mesh stage which are
performed by the adversary
we also know that the one revocable
algorithm implies a bound of i on the
recourse
these two results tell us that the
revocability is the pivotal measure of
maximal matching under vertex updates
on one hand we cannot have an efficient
algorithm even for decremental bipartite
graphs due to the above lower bounds and
on the other hand we can have an
algorithm which is one revocable and has
a constant update time
finally we switch our attention back to
the basic dynamic setting
and show an algorithm which maintains an
e over a minus one approximates mcm in
constant update time
this algorithm builds up the online
ranking algorithm by kbv
we also note that one can get the worst
case bound of
all one or epsilon of the recourse while
losing slightly the approximation
guarantee and the update time
the first
takeaway message
is that revocability is a more refined
measure of recourse
in particular we show that it is a
pivotal measure of maximum matching
algorithms
maximal matching algorithms
we can get an efficient one revocable
algorithm with a constant update time
whereas irrevocable algorithm requires a
linear update time
as i said this is a more refined measure
of recourse in particular an irrevocable
maximal matching algorithm implies a
bond of ofi on its recourse
we also study better than two
approximate mcm problem
in general grass it is still a major
open problem to get a better than two
approximation is some polynomial
uh update time under edge updates
and on the other hand we give a constant
time algorithm for maintaining a better
to approximate mcm under vertex updates
this algorithm builds on the online
ranking algorithm of kav90
this work draws connections between
online and dynamic algorithms in
particular our approximate mcm builds
heavily on the online algorithm of kdb
and the revocability parameter that we
use is inspired by irrevocability
restrictions underlying online
algorithms
we hope that a further study of these
two areas together rather than
independently will strengthen these
connections and unveil new ones and we
anticipate that ultimately this will
also advance the state of the art in
online algorithms
in this talk i will only go over our
result on one revocable maximal matching
the first algorithm that we present has
a
high bound on the recourse
but it contains the main ideas behind
the one revocable algorithm
and then i'll show the insights required
to achieve the water revocability
i'll start with the main intuition
behind the algorithm
an assumption that we use is that the
sequence of updates starts from an empty
graph whenever a vertex u gets inserted
in the graph the algorithm gets that of
degree of view credits
the interesting case is when a matched
vertex u gets deleted from the graph
for that case we observe that uh the
amount of credits that the algorithm
obtains is the minimum of the degrees of
its endpoints
and the guiding principle behind our
algorithm is that every edge uv in the
matching can borrow mean degree view
degree credits
from the neighbor that creates it
such a neighbor obtained these credits
upon its insertion into the graph
let's start with some definitions for
each vertex in the graph we maintain a
constant factor estimation of its degree
denoted by that prime
we partition the vertex sets into risky
vertices comprised of all the free
vertices
and all the matched vertices with
estimates degree larger by a factor of
two than their mains degree
and the same vertices
which are the mesh vertices with
estimated degrees smaller than twice the
degree of their mates
from the definition it follows that each
matched edge contains at most one point
that is risky
the intuition behind the names is that
safe vertices have enough of credits for
scanning their entire neighborhoods when
they become free
whereas risky vertices might not have
and we have to use some workarounds
for each vertex u in the graph we
maintain a partition of its neighbors
into safe and risky ones the risky set
is further partitioned into risky of
estimates degree at most the prime of
you and the ones of higher estimated
degree
the key invariant
that this algorithm maintains is that
for each risky vertex all these three
neighbors have their estimated degree
no greater than dec prime of u
we now dive into the
details of the algorithm
first we explain the easier case in
which we handle a save vertex in this
case we have double view credits so this
treatment should be trivial
the main challenge here is to maintain
all the data structures together with
invariant one which is crucial for
handling risky vertices
as i mentioned earlier a risky vertex
might not have enough of credits to scan
its entire neighborhood
first the algorithm scans uh the risky
neighborhood of larger estimated degree
and looks for a free vertex
if such a free free neighbor has been
found we matched to you
whenever some vertex changes from safe
to risky and vice versa we update its
neighbors about this change in time
linear in its degree
overall this takes all of the review
time
next if the set of neighbors of smaller
estimated degree is empty
you informs
its neighbors that it became free and
thus risky
the total cost of this part is all
degree of view and the invariant one is
maintained
finally if the set of neighbors of
smaller estimated degree is not empty
we have to take some extra steps in
order to maintain the invariance
first first
we take an arbitrary vertex w
and match it to you
while maintaining the data structures of
all the affected
neighbors
finally we handle uh the old mate of w
which is w prime recursively
ignoring the recursive call the total
update time of this part is again octet
of u and the invariant one is maintained
since you got matched
overall the total update time of the
first level of recursion is all of the
view
by the properties of risky and safe
vertices
we know that w prime has degrees smaller
by a factor of two than degree of u
and this allows us to bound the total
update time by a geometric sum which
evaluates to o of degree view
to argue the correctness of the
algorithm we observe that u is left free
only if you have no free vertices
in its risky neighborhood
we know that all its safe neighbors are
matched and the maximality follows
it remains to show how to handle a risky
vertex which is perhaps the most
interesting part of the update's
algorithm
due to invariant one we know that all
its three neighbors if it has any have
no greater estimates degree
if the set of these vertices is empty we
leave u unmatched
otherwise if it's not empty we take an
arby's very neighbor w
if w was previously matched we remove
this edge from m and add uw to the
matching and the vertex w which is the
old mate of
the vertex w prime which is the old mate
of w
this vertex is a safe vertex that became
free in order to maintain the data
structure and invariant one we invoke
handle safe on w prime
the total time this procedure takes
ignoring the call to handle safe is
proportional to degree of doubling
from the previous case we know that
handle safe also takes time proportional
to degree of topology
note that
u is a risky vertex and we might not
have enough of credits assigned to it
as a result we will charge the cost of
this procedure which is of degree of w
to the creation of the new matched
new matching edge uw
this is in check since every matched
edge can be charged across proportional
to the minimum of degrees of its
endpoints
another key point here is that edge w w
prime might have been previously charged
with some costs
but this cost is proportional to the
minimum of the degrees of its endpoints
which is degree of w prime
by the properties of risky and safe
vertices we know that w prime has degree
less than the
degree of w by a factor of at least two
which allows us to bound the total cost
assigns to uw by a geometric sound which
evaluates to of degree of double as
required
to argue the correctness of this
procedure we recall that u is left free
only if the sets are at most u is empty
and from invariant 1 it follows that u
does not have any free neighbors which
means that
the matching is maximum
we now summarize the charging scheme of
the algorithm when a vertex gets
inserted it gets handled as a save
vertex and the algorithm has
credits for that
the interesting case is when a vertex
becomes free due to its neighbor's
deletion
such a vertex u was either safe and the
deletion provides us reading off of
credits
or it was risky and we charge the cost
to a newly created edge
this concludes the description of our
highly revocable algorithm
we now proceed to explain the
ingredients required for obtaining a one
revocable maximal matching algorithm
first of all we define a new set of
vertices which we call the outliers
these are the same vertices that became
free
the guiding principle behind this
modified algorithm is that a say vertex
never removes any edge from m
whereas the risky vertex might remove
but at most one
the new invariant which we would like to
maintain
is that every risky vertex has
all its three neighbors either in the
set of outliers or in the set of risky
vertices of no larger estimated degree
the procedure for handling safe vertices
is as follows
we look for a free neighbor and matches
to you while maintaining the data
structures
if such a neighbor doesn't exist we mark
you as an outlier and update its
neighbors
the key point here is that while
handling a safe vertex we do not remove
any add from m
if u cannot be matched we instead mark
it as an outlier so as to maintain the
invariant one prime
to handle a risky vertex we distinguish
two cases
first if the set of outliers is not
empty
we take an arbitrary vertex from there
and matches to you here we recall that
all the outliers are free
otherwise we handle you as in the highly
revocable case
this treatment might render some vertex
w prime free
we know that the this vertex is safe
since it was matched to a previously
risky vertex
as we have seen handle safe does not
remove edges from m
this allows us to conclude that the
algorithm performs at most one removal
per update step
we have just shown how to maintain a one
revocable
maximal matching efficiently
note that the amortized update time of
our algorithm is constant
indeed the charging scheme that we saw
handles any updates within time linear
in the number of credits obtained from a
single vertex update that is assigned
uniquely to it
to summarize
this work initiates the study of
batching algorithms under fully dynamic
vertex updates
our main focus is on maximal matching
first we observe that there is a simple
irrevocable algorithm with constant
update time in bipartite graphs where
one side is fixed and the other side is
fully
dynamic second we show polynomial
amortized lower bounds on the update
time for revocable algorithms in the
medium dynamic setting where both sides
dynamically change
these lower bounds hold under the omv
and triangle detection conjecture
in contrast to these lower bounds we
present the one revocable algorithm with
constant amortized update time which
applies even to non-bipartite graphs it
works in the general dynamic setting
our findings identify the revocability
as a pivotal measure for maximum
matching algorithms in particular this
measure is more refined
than the recourse bound
for better than two approximations
we can get a one minus one overly
approximate algorithm for bipartite
graphs where one side is fixed and the
other dynamically changes
this algorithm relies heavily on the
classic online ranking algorithm of kvb
more specifically we show that the kvb
matching can be maintained dynamically
under arrivals and departures of clients
with constant
amortized update time
in the standard setting with edge
updates getting even a subpolynomial
update time is a major open problem
it would be interesting to see if we can
get anything for a setting between the
standard one of edge updates and the
basic dynamic setting of vertex updates
such as the medium dynamic setting where
both sides can change dynamic
in this work we demonstrate how the
insights from the area of online
algorithms can be used to advance
dynamic graph algorithms
despite the inherent connections between
these two areas of algorithms they have
been studied almost obviously
independently of each other
we anticipate that adorable study of
these two areas together rather than
separately will contribute significantly
to both